[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever
we want and we have mickey back how do
you like
rice balls you guys come with food yes
we do
we come with a lot of things yes you do
you said come and i can't what are you
immature i have to link it but what do
you both mostly come with i come with
um happiness yeah tell me more
and that's for all of you thank you for
shipping us we've been having fun with
you guys
we've been you have fun with it too i
think it's
great it's a great sport because anyone
else in that position like usually
people would be like
me this is fake
[Laughter]
and that's not fair he's like yeah
usually nobody is everyone's repulsed by
joe but you nikki you're so receptive
like usually everyone's like
oh who the [ __ ] would want this dude
that is not what i meant that's what you
were saying though
not what i meant to tell you that most
people are uptight and they won't roll
with the joke that's it
it's a joke a couple of minutes it's a
[ __ ] joke being in a relationship
with you is a joke not not what she said
yeah exactly that's exactly what i mean
you know what it
spewed over into social media and
everybody started
doing the whole like commentary on his
page coming to my page and they started
messaging us
then the same people started are you
guys just going to drag us along
yeah well we want to hang out so we
already established that we want to
spend time together and just do fun
stuff i mean you know i care
you do and by the way i don't think most
of you know that
we have really deep conversations off
camera we do yes very dear don't say
that because then they'll be like oh
steve what about nikki don't say no
no no no no we have they said about all
of us first off if you saw the no chase
if you saw the no chaser podcast which
you should go and check out as well
we all yeah it's way deeper and if you
think you gonna dig on that one
it's more likely that casey is gonna
jerk me off than
than but we all know that it's more
likely that bart is the most likely
person the most likely
which i've learned and it's a double
hander by the way
double hander mickey nicky your wife
yeah yeah
bart casey correct and then
maybe me or nelson and blake yeah no i'm
like
probably not me but yeah point being my
dude
he's a good boy we love him he's a great
man
but how likely is this actually don't
put us
on me and nelson are tired of being
[ __ ] with
tired of these games we're tired of the
emotional games you don't have to tell
them anything
like what hair here i'm gonna get it
okay let me put all my uh relationship
glasses right so
you don't have to tell them anything
don't [ __ ] with me we don't owe you an
explanation don't [ __ ] with me though
you know what if we decide to take this
any further off camera that's our
decision if we decide to bring the
camera along you're welcome oh i like it
what's private is private until we make
it public a potentially only fan
situation
oh i only public is how i roll okay
i asked house how is the
patreon because i don't have anything
extra i don't have nothing extra
and i know a lot of people that are on
the fans of only
and they are making yeah yeah
and i always wonder are there i support
it by the way are there
you would yeah if you want to do it you
would probably manage my account i'd
probably be in the account with
you probably would manage my account you
would be in a cash booth and money be
[ __ ] coming at you and you're [ __ ]
picking out of the air
the kind of guy i am is that if i know
that i'm negatively affecting your
career and your business i pretend that
i'm not with you anymore
see that's what that's why he pretended
he wasn't with his ex for so long and
that's so smart
you handed it to me you [ __ ] put it
right there
you're my brother you put it right there
oh [ __ ]
this is really good you could say
this is brought to you by juventus
what am i eating right now what is this
it's a mint taiko it's my favorite
flavor right now
we have it's made out of egg by the way
that's his [ __ ] business
there's a reason why it's his two and
hers
there's a reason why i get called back
is because i'm here for the advertising
yeah
i know how to do this yeah we like yeah
we like people
we support each other so nikki are you
going to sleep over
with you with me can i i'm
hold on a second what's going on here
wait that that came out of nowhere what
does that mean what does that mean to
you
yeah that's why i asked you if it was
okay um
what does it mean to you because you
talked about i misses steal your girl
and so it's like casey's like wait don't
you explore this casey's like i can't
wait
i'm gonna go ahead and she has no
involvement out there oh no involvement
are you gonna steal this girl don't see
those girls no they have there's legal
documents you probably want here to be
stolen through
yeah you have to want to be taken to be
stolen she wants to be taken
do you are you got to be taken by a
woman is that cool uh
have you ever jokingly yeah
in theory sounds great but really do we
want to deal with the issue
i get it it's not always cracked up dude
chicks are a nightmare bro
don't get with a bet don't get with the
truth i know yeah i i am one i know
i'm trying to one would you get with
yourself [ __ ] i i always tell
casey i'm like i don't know how you deal
with me same
i don't know how to deal with you when i
get bored i don't really deal with you
though
jesus because the world doesn't know
they don't know
they don't know they really don't know i
know true
i know you know yes yeah i know
case is a great man come on yes he's a
great guy
but back to our sleepover what happens
during the sleepovers yeah so we
tell us yes please do each other's hair
lick each other just kidding
i was like listen i have the whole
little gel kit that we can do each
other's nails
this is like a sleepover sleeper yeah we
have dildos
you hope one would hope they have a
double time to build up this
we're gonna die and then we have
vibrators
who can take the double-sided dildo the
deepest it's a fun game
great skincare routine that's how girls
have fun at sleepovers it rejuvenizes
all the collagen and stuff gets the
endorphins going
vibrating all inside if it starts with
hay come over i have wine
normally ends up in that route but if
it's just like we're gonna plant a
sleepover when girls make plants
we're like we're gonna follow through no
bring your nail kit
bring uh yes we have jackpots yeah we
have uh oh we have shady agents
which you don't know about don't know
about that you're going to learn i'm
going to learn today you're going to
teach me
sorry i didn't mean to i'm sorry that
was hard as [ __ ]
i'm like carry on very awkward in a
relationship for six years he's like oh
my god i'm
just kidding it feels like the beginning
of a porno that never starts
we just zoom out a little bit real quick
it's kind of like oh the sleepover
oh [ __ ] for that sleepover does big mood
have an only fans
no but maybe we should and it should be
the entry
of every porno but it doesn't ever turn
into a
very good by the way i was i've seen
you guys like set up and they're so cute
and everybody's in their little like
pajama [ __ ] and i don't have a lot of
girlfriends
you know growing up i'm like are you
saying you want to be invited to our
next sleep with every dream i've had
growing i just want to get the invite
how come you didn't have any
girlfriends because because my dad was
playing basketball my dad didn't let me
have friends
oh because were they afraid that you
would go to somebody's house and get
touched
uh because that was the thing i heard a
lot of girls were like you can't leave
the house cause then you know we don't
trust who their family members
never we were never allowed it's a
popular question yeah we were never
allowed to
have sleepovers i didn't really have
sleepovers and um i only went to
like my close friends and it was always
with sports so i didn't get i think now
as an adult i
really enjoy like let's all have dinner
like guys girls and doing the
housewarming type of things and the
cocktail parties and the game night so a
sleepover
we loved hosting stuff too but since the
pandemic like we haven't been able to
come over stay away yeah but as soon as
it's
you have a new backyard though congrats
[ __ ] but i haven't been there [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're invited [ __ ] i haven't
gotten me in that [ __ ] so
thanks [ __ ] well [ __ ] i told your wife
[ __ ] [ __ ]
ask her she's a [ __ ] i'm just kidding
it's all fun at games until you say well
she's a [ __ ]
she also never told me i'm a big new
mood on tuesday but apparently i am so
what are you and so is nikki
apparently we are there we go see you
then
see you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know it's all fun and games until
the [ __ ] comes from down here or they
say
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] really do you know
what i'm saying
it's like this [ __ ] and it's like [ __ ]
wait how do you do that i like that
bit like bad you gotta go hide look i
don't even have to say you know what
you know what i'm doing right now you
know what i did so you're giving it
you're taking it back
i like that right take this [ __ ] and
then you pull it back you know
it's like a snake strike man right now
yes
[ __ ] i love vermin rock i love bremen
he's like
good morning [ __ ] singer songwriter
actor
yeah scientist coconut milk connoisseur
he's bomb nikki blades what do you need
in a man that's lacking right now that
my friend joe can
first stop i don't need help no
i'm not saying you need help it's a
random [ __ ] question
sure as [ __ ] was a random question the
sleepover i could go back to the
sleepover yeah
okay wait wait what was the what was the
the juicier stuff sir what was the
sir was what no what do you need in a
man that my friend uh that
the people that i can provide people can
provide he's providing benefit
did you forget we we have a business
arrangement that's exactly what i'm
looking for right
now that's really cool we we are did you
not hear he would support
my only fans if i decided to make it i
know he would with both hands
that's what i heard babe today uh so he
asked for you to put your foot in this
cup
and then uh for me to drink out of it
he sent us 2500 i
am going to drink your foot water would
you do personalized videos
no there's a shout out to my girls that
are on the only fan shout out to my
girls that are
on the only fans one of my good friends
uh is getting [ __ ] cashed out and i
know how it goes but listen that's why a
[ __ ] got a regular job
because i can't do it they're like you
just gotta make your feet look a certain
way and then put it by your butt
and then like there's some science to
this people have requests personally
so i know some porn stars they say
personalized videos is their whole
[ __ ]
it's their money and again get your
bread
and if you're struggling out there in
the streets there's too much money to be
made it just depends on how much of your
soul you want to sell
i'm not struggling but i'm pretty greedy
so i'm wondering
maybe i should do so i think you would
make a lot of money
on only i just don't want to go out into
the street though and then go
yo i know you from somewhere and i'm
like hold on man
is it from jk news nah i wanna [ __ ] your
booty
and i'm like oh no they're like oh no
you're the guy who jerks off on himself
yeah and they're like oh yeah
yeah that's me i need a picture i gotta
show my boyfriend this [ __ ] like can you
do the thing with your tongue you're
like ellie yeah like i did yes
true that's me if you did though
you would be buying our next house oh
yeah that's true
they make a lot of money i know
and i um apparently the world knows how
broke i am right now so
why was like the common question it was
like you moved out of your place you
just
you decided that you're not going to
make it anymore because he titled his
own video that way he [ __ ]
manipulated the game that way he knows
what he's doing this piece of [ __ ]
i live in a garage nikki yeah exactly
are you ready
to be with this he lives in the garage
for now because our house is being built
right now
being smart there we go he knows what he
knows what it is and by the way he lives
in a garage with a private chef like
[ __ ] off really and we get to borrow
kids
first off yeah and they're [ __ ] cute
they're adorable
so cute then you have the saltwater pool
correct yeah
no bleach that's why the dog always
drinks from it do you know what i'm
saying and like listen
it's called being smart that's why the
rich stay right
yeah and let me live is like thank you
for backing me up i got you
i i live in a garage guys he wants to be
viewed as poor
i'm a simple man that's right i am a
simple man in a garage right
with the tea thing being built somewhere
somewhere somewhere it's gonna be in
darren's house yeah uh yeah
we're gonna build it in there he's gonna
uh start renting out his place for photo
shoots and stuff all right listen
okay i've had a lot of people ask me
about my dating life and what i look for
in a guy
and so many people are like if i was
rich or if i was famous i would totally
hit on you i was like first off that is
definitely not how to get i mean
i was like that isn't i was a better man
yeah
i've been waiting to turn somebody into
a stay-at-home dad you're like um i'm
into a guy with pigtails who wears a
junebe shirt
figure it out one ponytail not pigtails
today well
not today not today my bad this is just
a handlebar from when i'm eating [ __ ]
that's right there we go it's good
design
you talk about eating that and i'll just
put the rice ball in my mouth
i was like he's talking about eating
what
joe how do you eat it buddy how do you
do it like a rice ball
yeah i i've heard that um
i'm an artist i've heard that you've
been passionate some
majestic works yeah do you like being uh
being controlled then because you're
offering the ability for
for control i'm just a giving person i
don't think i'm actually
i guess i'm more of a switch but i can
be submissive but it's more like
with permission i can what is it if you
get your thumbs
up if you get this dom permission huh
when i'm on my all fours and i'm giving
my ass
with permission is dumb i give you
permission yeah
oh so you're giving the permission for
you to be submissive exactly
okay i'm still in control here got it
you're going to like my halloween
costumes oh [ __ ] what is it
what do we got oh what is it
wait dominatrix [ __ ] well i like cat
like uh
full body suit so like cat suits so i i
have the red ranger
like full red ranger wait not the pink
green
not nunk or yellow listen they were all
out of them oh
red is what i got red is what i got and
then um an all black
leather one with what's supposed to be
like venom then i'll be alpha
alpha alpha five oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah my butt is not protected oh my
god
i would not know it i would be like this
oh
god no no no no no he's like i guess we
found similar costumes
what would you do if you're like yeah
baby get dressed up for me oh i'm so
ready for you and they showed up in like
a polar opposite outfit of what you
expected
what would be a no outfit what would be
i would show up at zordon and i'd be
like nikki
i hate to break it to you but i have a
mission
you gotta [ __ ] alpha five it's not the
best situation
but you are a ranger you are a ranger
and i come in like i guess this mission
we have to do together
that would be the worst porn ever yeah
that'd be so terrible okay what would be
a
no like what's an absolute no what is a
i will not
what do you mean like what costume is
going to turn no what is something that
will turn you off period
it's going to be really hard for you to
turn me off
yeah like having casey dressed up as
something
yeah no
[Laughter]
my [ __ ] no thank you he was any sort
of like woman character or like a baby
because baby character popped in my head
i'm like oh
that's a nose yeah hard no me child no
diapers
although i did watch this portal though
and a girl was wearing a onesie and that
was [ __ ] hot
i think women have an easier time
finding
like the diversity of the outfits yes
that was kind of hot but she wasn't
acting like a baby
that's weird no she just had a giant
penis
if she did this [ __ ] like what the [ __ ]
that's disgusting she just had a giant
[ __ ] that could come
what like fountains of what no i'm not
oh no no he's talking about this okay he
found this funny part it's not even
something he was into it's
it's different yeah he sent it to you no
no no no no
no it's it's just something he told me
is a joke yeah
but what are you interested in me yeah
like if you would dress up as something
yeah any dress up are you guys what
about pippy
no maybe um i mean the first thing that
popped in my head that would be kind of
cool is like aquaman
jason mamoa notes guys taking long the
long hair and the tattoo
i wanted to take you to grow a beer uh a
[ __ ] a million years
it's time to start it takes him never
what about okay so a little
a little aquaman jason mamoa jason mama
jon snow
comic book bright orange green pants huh
give him some
freckles
he's aquaman he dyes his hair blonde
aquaman from is it aquaman from
spongebob
um you know what i'm talking about
mermaid mermaid man
could you imagine like baby dressed up
like aquaman this is
apartment you got the wrong point fish
over here you didn't even get the muscle
suit underneath
the seashell bra no
you know what though girls can pull off
ridiculous outfits
as sexy though but guys we just look
ridiculous man
i still think the mailman ups
guy actually suit and tie
suit and
postal workers and you with ups guys
like horny as [ __ ] they're like
i think i still think you like the short
shorts with the socks
a little bit yeah you like the white hat
that they wear the little for the for
the sun do you wear them do you like
that
you know why what grandpa is dropping
off your mail a lot of a lot of them
wear their [ __ ] arms a lot of safari
guys are dropping off
the safari guys yeah yeah i like i like
the suits i still like an actual like
suit
like like a business suit oh my god
same dude because like for our wedding
when he was wearing the suit all like oh
this suit with this cat has some [ __ ]
suits though this cat has some fun
he looks good escobar suits oh i'm not
kidding actually
your hype game is immaculate i'm not
kidding though prove it
no i'm angry at him for having these
killer suits because they're so sick
they make my suits look like [ __ ]
haven't you seen him look all like suave
and mafioso like this oh there it is
this cat i'm telling you man it's just
how does it feel being so
like you're literally being pimped out
to me right now how does that make you
feel
it's not even that hard show her the sex
appeal show her the sexy
recreate recreate can't look me in the
eyes
you know what it is i'm [ __ ] jealous
i'm jealous of this guy yeah i'm jealous
of him
i wish i was him honestly
[Music]
you
[Music]